what does it actually look like on the
ground there um are russians
just attacking military compounds in
airports or are they attacking civilians
too
they are attacking everything right now
the reality is they weren't successful
in trying to sweep the country fast
which they aim to do
and that's why essentially they are
involved in all out fighting on all
different lines in the western media it
says that russia has been attacking
ukrainian civilians is that true
absolutely
supporting the civilians in ukraine we
are giving food to those people we are
entering into the territory uh the tons
of products
because
in the cities who are now
more relaxed like milital for example we
have seen the footages when the soldiers
are giving food to our brothers because
these are our brothers
hey there i'm michaela peterson this is
my podcast i regularly do episodes
called opposing views where i get two
people on to share their views on
contentious subjects i don't want to
downplay how serious the invasion of
ukraine by russia is by calling this an
opposing views episode i'm not taking
this lightly i had the opportunity to
interview two people one nikolai
burleigh nikolai is part of the russian
government and svyatislav yorosh
he is a ukrainian politician he's the
youngest ukrainian member of parliament
he has a crazy story he was previously
the euro maiden press center organizer
and senior spokesperson for zielinski's
2019 presidential election campaign
he's currently in kiev and has taken up
arms against the russian military
i asked him similar questions to nikolai
and he also went into details about what
it actually looks like in ukraine on the
ground
nikolai is part of the russian
government part of the state duma which
is like the elected parliament first
deputy chairman of the committee for the
development of civil society public and
religious association issues and member
of the orthodox patriarchal council for
culture he was also an actor for most of
his life something that isn't viewed
like hollywood is viewed in the west
it's a prestigious job particularly
during the soviet union
he came on to discuss the russian
government's perspective of what's
happening it was done through an
instantaneous translator so it might be
a bit choppy i'm not interested in
contributing to censorship
shedding rt russia today
down the russian government's news
source like some platforms have i think
is a mistake
russia blocking facebook and twitter
from their citizens something i would
have asked nikolai about except it
happened after we spoke is a mistake we
can't understand the motivations behind
actions without clear communication we
don't know what's true without looking
at all perspectives
and the more lines of communications are
kept open the more likely there's peace
i think for whatever that's worth i've
linked what your ash spoke about in the
show notes if you're interested in
donating there's a bank account listed
there
welcome to my podcast
thank you very much your interests and
the fact that you care means a great
deal i'm a big fan
good okay well i'm really excited to
talk about what you've been doing
because
things are insane right now so before we
get started can you give a brief
background about who you are and what
you do
so i come from the west of ukraine
after finishing the school there i went
to study in poland then i went to study
to india
and that's when the revolution in my
country started in 2014. so i came back
from my to my country for the revolution
during the revolution i started and
headed the international
center of the mind and that with
foreigners internationals
media diaspora and embassies
we had a social media we started to
transmit
all about the events during the
revolution to the world in various
languages
i got a medal for that
then i went to the war 2014.
i was a journalist there um basically
seeing how a beautiful city like dometsk
was turned into hell
through the russian uh
incursion and transformation
of that wonderful rich region and then i
went to kiev where i did many things
which led me to not support the
president
incumbent and support his competitor
who's now the president of ukraine and
after the elections
uh i was invited to join in
as a member of parliament i did and i
became the youngest member parliament of
ukraine
okay that was quite an intro
that was great uh okay i've got a couple
of questions about what you said so you
said
you came back um for the revolution in
the war in 2014. so for anybody
listening who might not be aware that
there was a revolution in war can you
describe what that was
i'm sorry i'm just not used to
hour-long podcasts they are wonderful to
me but as far as the
reality of my presentations we have to
brief and get like no i like brief
brief is perfect
that that's what i didn't expect so
basically uh i thought my youthful
adventure that your father speaks about
will be basically somewhere in india and
that's why i went to essentially because
poland was quite in ukraine done right
if i can describe it briefly in terms of
reform and change and economic progress
and all that
and after that point uh you know you
desire something that is wholly
different from what you came from and
that's why i went to
india but at that point our president
who was the president of point chose to
renege on his promises of the european
union
path and that's when the
students came up on the streets to try
and protest that action i was not sure
about coming back to that point but then
he beat them up
and that caused a huge uproar and the
millions of people were coming up the
streets essentially sweeping uh a
central key of our capital from uh all
the police forces there and started a
huge camp called the mai don
which became sort of a center point for
the events and the next two months when
the president
essentially fled the country as the
result of protests and new elections was
held and russia decided to
to react by annexing crimea
and starting an award in eastern ukraine
so that's again long story short
okay okay and then what's been going on
in donetsk
in donetsk basically uh the reality was
in 2014 uh this was a city
it was registered in ukraine by many
measurements because much
good
elites come from donetsk and they've
been essentially investing heavily in
that town and when i arrived in april
2014 i wasn't expecting
and nobody was expecting to become what
it did become
that is with the russian
russian
auxiliaries and russians moving in and
trying to set up these puppet republics
uh turning that
city into hell of uh marauders and
basically the solution of every
every structural state in donetsk and
basically when i arrived in april 2014 i
was just coming from the maidan and the
revolution that those russian proxies
hated
with the passion and the reason why it
wasn't captured because i was working
foreigners
so they basically did not know me so it
was internationals that knew me and not
the uh not the ukrainian crowd so the
fact of the matter is because of the
events in 2000
and 2014 and the revolution uh i got a
chance to then travel to netsk and had
to invent my new identity to survive
there from april to august of 14th so i
plan to be a polish producer i work with
fox news for the entire time
and because of my very bad russian as i
come from western ukraine we didn't
about the first generation did not study
russian school so my russian is
no unbearable but uh it's clearly not uh
ukrainian russian
basically and that's how i survived
there and after mh17 that the plane the
malaysian plane that was shot down over
eastern ukraine
by the russian missile systems uh
basically
that's the point
i would say two weeks or three weeks
after that point and i then left the
nets going to kiev and doing many things
many institutions for many reasons in
many capacities trying to be sort of a
dilettante
man of many professions but basically
training in two things first information
and second trying to connect good people
with
good initiatives and
getting many things going off the ground
and
basically at that point i had a chance
to see the reality of what the president
then
represented and i thought that i could
not support that so that's why when mrs
lenski announced that he was running for
the presidency i joined him
a month after he announced and
that's my political career starting out
do you think any of the war going on now
is a discrepancy between what older
people who lived in the soviet union
want and what younger people want or do
you think most ukrainians want the same
thing
you can look at the polls and
measurements they clearly point that
there is uh there is certainly much
skepticism about european direction but
after 2014 of next session and after the
war with russia in the east as far as
the polling is concerned it's not
exactly split in the middle the reality
is
a majority wants to
go to the west and then the other big
side is people don't
know clear minority basically is in
support of any russian moves but again
after the events that are happening
right now that minority is shrinking to
nothing the point is putin's on
everything possible to try and
destroy any russian discourse in ukraine
politics when i debate for russian
politicians uh in various different
media channels in ukraine
they shudder even to try and uh save
their prussian they must cis like points
like neutral and all that
because to say that you're prussia in
ukraine right now is an impossibility
before the revolution it was quite easy
to say that you operation and to say
that you basically uh are for the
alignment of our country with russia but
after these events and after response to
them by mr putin he destroyed
any
good will there was for russia in
ukraine's side
okay
okay
okay question number two
uh okay what is it what does it actually
look like on the ground there um are
russians
just attacking military compounds in
airports or are they attacking civilians
too they are attacking everything right
now the reality is they weren't
successful in trying to sweep the
country fast which they aimed to do
and that's why essentially they are
involved in all out fighting on all
different lines and ukraine and russia
it's very important to describe the
scales here so ukraine is the biggest
country in europe proper
and russia's biggest country in the
world
so the point is we share more than a
thousand kilometer border with russia
and we share about 500 kilometers of
border with their puppet belarus to our
north uh they have attacked on each and
every front line uh and including uh
attempts to try and seize the southern
ukraine by landing some marines there so
we essentially are fighting on every
single front line in every single
direction against the russian forces
which are using everything in their
power to try and overwhelm us and still
they are not able to
okay
i'm sorry um what's on the ground
reality is it's
a country that is changing extremely
fast in last 10 days from a country
which was
same as any european country travel to
so nice
you know people drinking your decaf
latte
with soy milk somewhere in nice coffee
shop
for five dollars
with people on
driving on the
teslas
this was a this was a wealthy european
town here that is and life here was as
with every european capital
basically and it's now uh
it's mostly abandoned as far as the
activity of
citizens but as far as people joining up
and getting into the stations is full up
and cities building barricades building
tank traps
getting everything
ready for a full russian invasion and as
i speak to you basically i just heard
that the russian tank column 40
kilometers long which is staying uh
north of here started to move on to cave
so who knows when i will be talking and
what capacity
uh a few hours from now
oh my gosh this is so awful
i'm so sorry for you know whatever
that's worth this is awful
okay
it's very important lesson that you can
learn here you don't see a city like any
other turned in no time into hellscape
the reality is it's just
people don't know how
how small it is the barrier between
normality and madness
and you see how it happens here but the
reality is no madness we are facing it's
the unique example of unity because with
putin advancing and trying to take
ukraine
which he has consistently tried to do
with the last 20 years of his power uh
ukraine is the united stand so people
are doing everything in their power to
try and beat back the attacks we have on
our capital and everywhere else
okay we covered a bunch of questions i
want to ask at the beginning
why do some russians believe ukraine is
actually russia why is that part of the
rhetoric that's going on why do you
think it's quite simple the russian
textbook and history starts with our
capital it starts hearing here i mean
there's a battle of myths happening here
so the russian myth
essentially is that
there was a big state central key of
kievan rus uh which was essentially a
big state
powerful
european state which was smashed by the
mongols
mongol invasion
and a chunk of it survived the north
around moscow and that chunk got
stronger and stronger and stronger and
after a while
beat back the mongols
uh conquered all the old lands back and
even conquered some more and that's
basically the reality of that unity of
all nations
as but we are saying ukrainians we never
left we never went anywhere so we
were still we were still here the whole
time when he had joined stay with poles
with lithuanians with other nations
around us and the reality is that we
basically in that time
where
the
thesis of kievan rus state uh
essentially was separated but mongolia
have developed a whole new and very
clear and identity which you can see
right now with ukrainians trying to
fight back against second biggest army
in the world
and the reality is that there's a saying
the russian liberal ends where the
question ukraine begins
uh which basically means that
russians have this tendency of seeing
our nation's part of their nation for
many reasons but it's you know
canadians can relate to us it's as if
you know america would say that canada
is america basically you know because it
speaks english comes from the same
empire and therefore should be a part of
uh should be part of america it's the
same idea of itself but canadians see it
differently and the same story goes for
ukrainians even though there are
characteristics which are of similar
nature um basically that
that separate identity has forged
especially in these battles of the last
eight years on the support line and now
every single day it's getting stronger
and stronger
okay that makes sense
why is putin saying there are nazis in
the ukraine
well it's the reality of what that man
is i mean that man grew up in the
time after the second world war
when he basically
got
the soviet propaganda and which was
about that everybody is a nazi and
so some people trying to try to point
out that the west basically is
nazi friendly or taking up nazis or
playing with them in terms of
integrating them in societies and into
power structures and basically trying to
save their nazis in one way or the other
so as far as putin is concerned he is
trying to use the old soviet troops
soviet technology to submit ideas about
the world try and force his imperialism
onto ukraine but it's because people are
saying the putin is mad religion is this
and that putin is very consistent about
one thing uh that it's the fact that he
sees ukraine's russians the same people
and uh in his rhetoric over the last
eight years he's been trying to bring
that around with various instruments but
now seeing that electorally he has no
future in ukraine none of his parties on
his property really are gaining traction
or attention or support he
uh basically has turned to one
instrument that he thinks history will
redeem him
from that is violence and invasion but
history has an option opinion
of despots which invade countries as you
might
remember from basic history lessons
okay
um
what role does nato play if any in
causing russia to attack
well russia sees russia explains the
story with nato expansion as if it's
against russia the reality is nato
expansion actually was about those
countries in central europe which faced
russian aggression firsthand
uh
turning somewhere for
that security which they didn't have
when they experienced the prague spring
when they experienced the
hungarian uh revolution in the soviet
times consuming invasion
for that
the soviets did everything possible for
these countries not to feel safe on
their own with russia in the
neighborhood so of course they try to
join that alliance which
proposed and offered security uh against
the possibility of russian invasion and
we see that it does work because without
estonia small country uh in the baltic
region um
it's basically has right in the world of
russia a huge region which is full of
russians like 93 russian actually and uh
there is no uh people's republic there
there is no russian forces no russian
forces moving into the area this is very
simple it's only the nato so it's
impossible to try and uh try and
do that without the repercussions the
russia actually fears so the point is
that russia sees nato expansion
basically as
a step against their
ability to control the region that it
sees as its own region while these
countries have different ideas choosing
their own future and choosing their
future exactly because of russian
aggression away from russia and choosing
a future with the west which is more
prosperous more successful and more
secure than what russia is offering
so the
the
person i talked to who
was from the russian government
his
view
it sounded like and i could be
completely misunderstanding this but it
sounded like
they were potentially scared that nato
was going to take over russia that the
end goal of nato was to actually consume
russia do you think that's just
rhetoric or do you think that there's an
actual fear that nato is going into
russia
i'm sure it's actually fear it's fear
that those western institutions
democracy real democracy which promote
transparency and to want uh your
your politicians not to have a huge
swiss bank accounts with millions
on them and not steal money from your
people that those systems will actually
hold and try to
run
as a desire for your nation i mean
there's a huge fear of those
institutions in the west which are as
imperfect as they are they are trying to
lead and bend
the democratic world to try and destroy
that possibility of
you know your country's leaders becoming
those kleptocrats and dictators who
essentially are holding money from your
nation into their own private ambitions
that sort uh of course russia is afraid
of uh
the opposition uh to the reality of this
regime that's why the league initially
this in russia aren't so much focusing
on nato or ukraine they focus on
corruption they are pointing this time
and time again the corrupt nature of
russian government and the absolutely
right that all these
stories about nato and the west and this
and that the other there's all excuses
for russia trying to
keep the system in hands which
essentially arranges the queue while
destroying life so many but i think mr
putin is beyond that i mean it's to put
in its reality being powerful all this
time doesn't really think about
elections or social opinion polls he
thinks about historical legacy and
historical legacy that he wants for
himself as he said himself many times is
the united russian peoples as he says it
so somebody who will bring it into the
full ukraine belarus and try and
showcase that even though the soviet
union is no more that he can do this he
can provide an image
of a country which essentially can still
come back to historical claims
the reality is that
the ukrainians you know when when they
travel to poland when they see a first
village out of the border
of the border they see that people live
better there you don't need economic uh
graphs or big analysis to see that but
just look at the reality of people
living there and they see this as a fact
when they go to russia they don't see
that they don't see what is that to
aspire to a starting civilization model
they don't see economic progress
they see a state in which there is no
possibility to protest no possibility to
voice your position of any in anything
and
basically they see a state which is
essentially coming back to what we left
in the soviet union
trying to essentially re-establish those
systems
that despise liberty
not just
crack down on but despise it and
essentially destroy every single
restitution of free society that is in
russia i mean this week actually my
favorite radio station in russia was
closed down radio stations for 15 years
30 station which i adore basically for
every single week i listed podcasts from
that radio station
as a ritual of mine in a sense and that
playstation uh very curious story of why
it remained all the time in russia but
it's dead now and that's all the result
of which is policing possible
that not even a voice of opposition can
be allowed not even a voice of descent
can be provided for
that's not something inspired we are
freedom loving peoples have always been
that's why the story of ours always went
to
kozaks you know people who left serfdom
in the polish state they went to the
steps in the south uh of ukraine and
tried to establish their free communes
of people that would essentially be
defending against the tata raids coming
to ukraine to sort of get
slaves for the ottoman slave markets and
essentially the point here is that uh
freedom is essentially one strain that
goes throughout our history and this
russian russian state has the opposite
objective and that's why ukrainians are
not fans of that
integration shall i be diplomatic
yes
yes i can see that do you think that
this is going to
do you think for russia this is going to
end in another iron curtain i know that
yesterday they shut off
facebook i think something else as well
and twitter and twitter and instagram
they're shutting up everything because
we have basically the award in ukraine
providing for a lot of imagery
a lot of it and that imagery is
from the hundreds of
thousands now
i've captured pows
explaining their story uh the for
example the call of our minister defense
for russian mothers to come to ukraine
and pick up their captured sons i mean
we actually invited if you want to
retake your captured son just come to
ukraine we'll give it give him to you
uh they don't want russians to know that
they don't russians to
hear of descent in different parts of
russia uh basically the shot of the idea
that in russia there's any other opinion
about mr putin's opinion uh the reality
is everything has gotten worse for
anybody who loves freedom in russia and
wants to aspire to it and believe me
over the years just a day before the
invasion i was speaking with
office uh well
former head of the north office of mr
navalny who's the main opposition figure
in russia uh it saved this exactly about
this problem so the fact that
russians ukrainians as uh that ukrainian
russians is this but this dialogue
between them uh is not maintained and
should be rekindled and rebuilt uh and
unfortunately a day after that we have
invasion so the reality is that
putin is destroying any image of that
and he's trying to force his image of
history and the future on to ukraine
through war and the war that everybody
sees about his own nation
wow
ah okay
why
well is this true and if so why why was
the russian language banned in ukraine
it was not banned there was never
abandon ban on russian language in
ukraine the fact of the matter is uh
actually our constitution provides for
the free use of russian language
basically
spells it out that national language is
ukrainian but
as far as the use of regional language
regional languages
and russians should be allowed for in
every single way that was a what would
you refer to i imagine this is the point
that many russian began this point to is
that during the time this president
who essentially fled the country after
the revolution 2014
my revolution uh basically they adopted
this regional language law
providing for different regions of
ukraine to be able to have regional
languages as well as the national
language and after the revolution there
was
uh basically an attempt by
one of the three opposition parties to
repeal this law
it was passed in the parliament but then
it was not signed by the president
acting pressing approach so it was not
even
not it was not
brought down by that uh there was no
vote even to repeal this regional
language as well regional language is
large simply means that you know you
could for example
go to government institutions and use
russian laws ukraine and that's that's
that and as far as the languages
language discussion in ukraine i mean
the point is this discussion is no more
the reality is that this war
unites everybody and believe me my
opinion language issue in ukraine
general has shifted a great deal because
of the revolution and during the war in
the east i saw many people who who have
done everything imaginable to support
and
live for ukrainian who died for ukraine
and they spoke russian and all that
process and as far as my position
language issue i truly believe that
ukrainians come in all stripes informed
ukrainians are russian speaking
ukrainian speaking and it doesn't really
make a difference to god speaking
russian doesn't make you russian
speaking russian
russian is one of the
one of the languages certainly the
languages of the u.n so as far as
the fact that some ukrainians speak
russian sure but ask them who they
identify as
and
like the same canada here and
speaking french doesn't certainly make
you french uh that assumption is faulty
is the same as speaking english in
uh in canada doesn't make you english
it's you can be canadian as well so to
assume here that everybody who speaks
russian in ukraine is russian or that
you could ban a language which at least
half relations speak every day is
madness uh i i was married to for a long
time to a lady
who spoke russian i spoke ukrainian and
basically um you know it's it was an
issue at all
okay good answer i don't know actually
in canada i'm sorry again because in
ukraine reality is somebody can speak
russian i can keep training with them we
miss each other perfectly
that's how we communicate yeah i know
whether it's english or french that way
yeah no
no but i i get what you mean though like
people from quebec are not france french
they're just canadian kind of
i don't know if they identify as
canadian exactly but i get what you mean
you do
yeah yeah quebecois exactly
um
okay do you think it's r is this true
and if so do you think it's reasonable
that men currently can't leave ukraine
uh that is mobilization happening in
ukraine immobilization means that every
able-bodied man 18 to 60 uh is dropped
into the army because again our nation
is facing an attack on all of our
thousand miles with russia facing
incursions
and actually in russian invasion from
belarusian border which is 500 miles
long and facing
not infrequent
marine
invasion from the south of ukraine so
the point is everybody is needed as much
as possible and actually i'm trying to
help organize some of the foreigners and
some of the astronaut people who want to
join ukrainians by descent who want to
join the fight because in this fight in
this onslaught everybody's needed like
they were never needed before
is what the media portraying in the west
true because we've had so much
misinformation with kovid that a lot of
people have lost faith in anything the
mainstream media is reporting so from
what you've seen from mainstream media
is is that an accurate portrayal of
what's happening
well we have cruise cruise missiles
fired on ukrainian cities we have
children dead women and we are fighting
all across the border we have
residential buildings destroyed by the
fighting about 20 kilometers from where
i sit right now uh i was coming to those
towns
both to fight and to try and provide
humanitarian things which i can gather
and the reality is that in all of this
uh the fact of the matter is we are
facing an onslaught by the second
biggest army in the world like destroy
our nation consuming whole and if
allowed russia destroying the largest
nation in europe uh would essentially
mean the whole
destruction of the international
system of law and order
these things should not happen in this
century as they told me when i was
growing up but they are happening and we
are trying to resist because again
for people like myself
when they think about their family
history my great grandfather went to
stalingrad and he went on to liberate
europe
my great grandmother has lived through
all the more genocide by hunger
and the ukrainian people so the fact of
the matter is they survived this and
this horrible 20th century for my nation
and in the end of the century we got to
live in an independent state
then who
who if not asked should try and preserve
that gift
that they gifted us and try and further
it and build it up into the future
so
what do you think's going to happen here
you have like what's your guess
well it depends on russia so if russia
tries to mobilize russia tries to throw
in more resources we will have a long
drawn-out battle which will cost dearly
but again we are here fighting for our
country for our nation for our land for
our future and we are not going to back
down we are very clear that we want to
be independent nation signing its own
story and uh so we will fight no matter
what russia throws at us
we will fight what do you think the
world's response should be to this
well first russia has broken every
single rule in the international
guidebook so it's not just here now but
throughout the 20 years of its business
russia has basically destroyed every
single idea about what national ocean
being uh around the world speak that in
venezuela with the central african
republic
or be there in ukraine so the point here
is that russia needs to be thrown out
almost every single institution that
it's part of because it doesn't deserve
any current with kind of leadership to
have any
play in the national institutions
it doesn't respect it stress and tries
to destroy manipulate and uh essentially
use its own imperialistic ambitions in
the region uh but the reality at hand is
that
that's only the first part the second
part is as far as the fight happening
around ukraine nothing is enough
we are in need of everything and
anything
uh in this fight i mean
i spent good chunk of my day
trying to bring different supplies
different parts of the front line and uh
basically
we welcome all the help we are getting
from the west but we need so much more
to try and have a chance against one of
the
biggest armies in the world second
biggest if you believe numbers
okay are do you know
like if people listening want to help
somehow do you know ways they can do
that i'm sure they're going to be
comments about that
yes and there's actually an official
bank account that our national bank of
ukraine started to try and allow anybody
who wants to donate to us have a direct
pathway to it um and also there's uh all
these humanitarian organizations who are
spring into action uh almost all of them
have tried to reach out to support our
fight uh in different ways
for the humanitarian needs that millions
of ukrainian refugees now crossing the
borders into poland or romania have or
just saying the western ukraine have so
the point here is that
all of that is very much available and i
cannot give you top of my head the exact
numbers the bank account ukraine
government has started for example but
uh
much of it was sharing social media i'm
basically seeing lots of links
sent to all of that
okay well we ran through the questions i
have i can't thank you enough for coming
on and talking about what's going on
there um is there anything else you'd
like to say i think that this episode
pro probably get i mean there's a war so
people are going to watch it so is there
anything else you want people to know
about that we haven't covered
our nation is fighting war it's freedom
for its chance to choose its future we
have very similar problems to all of you
we have politicians we don't like we
have politicians who fail the
oppositions who have i hope
that they represent and we were in this
paradigm for the longest time
and russia is trying to destroy all of
that and take our freedom away from us
just trying to build the puppet state of
various kind we will fight until the
last don't let it happen and the point
for us is that uh
i i
sincerely thank everyone who is sending
everything
starting with prayers and words because
we are god fairy nation so for us those
prayers mean a lot but also the question
of the support that you find on various
social media channels that send uh all
the understanding about
impossible help to ukrainian army and
ukrainian mentality efforts everything
is very welcome and again this
understanding the world is watching and
the world's behind us makes us more
certain in our defiance to try and stand
up for our freedom and again it's just
in a long line of people who are
fighting for that throughout the
centuries so we will continue to fight
no matter what comes our way
well i hope this doesn't
i hope things get better um if people
want to follow you or learn more where
should they go
i'm on twitter i'm on instagram i'm
my name is very slavic and i apologize
for my parents who named me not thinking
about national audience who might have a
problem spelling that name when amir was
in india they tried to shorten by saying
not scatter slave but sweet love
and i
uh
as
my
instagram is basically s underscore
y-u-r-a-s-h so you rush that's my
surname and my
twitter is my name ua so that's that's
long and slavic i apologize seattle
iat os yeah that's the easier way
because
trying to
have a spelling bee here with ukrainian
names is not
easy for anybody so yeah thank you very
much for your interest and i must say
michaela uh i did not i don't know
whether this latest debate of yours in
oxford uh
between the vegans and meat eaters have
been published but i was right before
the war i was trying to find it and
couldn't find it still it's up now
it's not as dramatic as what you're
going through but it's pretty funny if
you need it he needs something to laugh
at it's on my channel your father was
speaking about his podcast and i was
sort of trying to uh trying to find it
as well so and i haven't read the 12
more rules for life i just bought it and
basically the war is taking that chance
away from you but you have deep respect
for you and your father and the work
you're doing to bring this weaving
enlightenment to many people who are
trying to find meaning in their life
which is far more precious
than anything and as i say the war the
war basically brings you that meaning as
nothing else because it gives you
understanding what uh your nation's all
about when you see all these people
lining up and trying to battle and fight
and die for their country you see that
your nation is real and that aspiration
that you have is even more so
okay well thank you very much for coming
on good luck good luck over there
so good luck i'll send prayers
thank you mikaela
nikolai welcome to my podcast
thank you
before we get started uh could you give
me a brief background about who you are
and what it is you do
professor
in my yeah
i am actor and
i
work in movies
industry i
was filmed in 70 films 70 movies
and some of these movies
all the times of all the nations nations
like andrei darkowski andre
and the childhood of ivan ivan
russian
and
i also were
delivering my own movies and as andre
tarkowski told every movie should be a
statement
and i have two uh full length movies and
four uh short uh movies and three
documentaries
and also
this year i became the deputy of russian
state duma
i am the professor of two or three
academies and saint petersburg academy
of
movie making and theater and television
academy
serbian academy of arts
and i am a member at the patriarch
council for culture
at the uh russian orthodox church and
there are many other things that i'm
doing basically
okay great well thank you again for
coming to join me to talk about what
we're going to talk about
okay
question number one
i think it would be good to give the
listeners in the west a background of
the history between russia and ukraine
so could you give me a brief history
about russia and ukraine in the last 15
years
yes of course
let's start with
father of the father of my father was a
colonel at zappa roger and his name was
kandra
and
at that time there was the gatman bogdan
militsky who sent him with
the plea
to join uh to make a join between
ukraine and russia and i am the direct
descent of this particular kosak who
went to russia and asked
ukraine to be a part of the russia and
we have a long history between us and
ukraine
not to love ukraine we love ukraine so
much we love the people we love the
songs and we know that
these people are uh
every time joining us at
one on the same table and during the 30
years ukraine was ill and i've seen this
disease in the development of this
disease
i came to
ukraine in 1992 when it was detached
from russia
and this
was uh
not a natural breach between the
countries
and this was made in a synthetic way and
this was made by three judahs of slavic
world so to say yeltsin in russia
ukraine the president the president of
ukraine
they had
and they had a meeting at the dark
forest i think that they took a bottle
of vodka and then they
assigned a huge country to die
and this country this huge country was
built by uh my uh
far relatives uh and they were
harmonizing during the centuries russia
and these three people could make the
thing that could not be uh made by tatar
mongolia
it was not done by a napoleon invasion
of russia
by hitler also
nobody could divide russia but these
three people could do this
they decapitated our country
they
made one folk
and divide they took one fork and
divided this into three
russians ukrainians belarussians are one
and the same nation i have people
whose blood is streaming in me from
russia from ukraine from belarus and
everything is mixed up here
and
i've seen it when i've started to make
rounds and rounds around the countries
in 1992 i was searching for the movies
for movie forum in moscow and i was
working
together with the ministry of culture of
ukraine and i was sitting in the hall
and by the way i have
a big set of friends in kiev and
there are also famous people from
culture and they brought movies and what
did i see already in 1992 i've seen it
that before if before in the soviet
movies
uh the main
evil guys where the ss people the
fascists the nazis who were burning some
ukrainian uh settlements who
were
terrorizing ukrainians uh who
were doing massacre but i've seen that
in the ukrainian movies or in 1992
the
biggest bad guys became the russians the
officers of uncovered their russian
special forces at the
uh soviet times who
were uh making horrible things and who
were uh
and by the way i was contacting
my friends uh through television and i
was asking them what are you doing you
are serving for the fastest for this 30
civs
30 silver coins and by the way the
process was started at that time and in
these 30 years my friends in ukraine
artists the
people's artists uh
the famous artists who were famous
already at the soviet time they've
started to support uh support
this russia russophobia the hate towards
russians against russians we've started
to speak uh anti-historical
things like we are different people
russians and ukrainians and this is
crazy how can you uh
take
me and cut me into pieces where i am
ukrainian where what piece of me is
russian and they made this generation
new generation of
russo folks and they introduced into
their understanding this notion that
russians
the bad guys our russians are the fines
and by the way i've understood that
without the serious operation without
cutting out without the deletion of this
fascism and nationalism in ukraine you
could not heal this country and now by
the way today
i've used the platform of our russian
parliament and i was connecting by the
television to our ukrainian brothers and
i told them we were 25 years at the site
of each other you were visiting me
uh on my movie forum
[Music]
the golden knight and i was bringing all
the ukrainians
and
into one group and they were seeing what
are the 19
countries of the world
making
in uh
what were the atrocities and they will
they had seen the atrocities they have
seen what happened in russia in 1993 for
example when yeltsin
put the order uh to use the tanks
against the white house against the
russian parliament
and
they have seen that at that time in 1993
in moscow
the third power was working there were
some special points
just
a very convenient ones and i will not
speak about the particular places but
there were some points from which the
people were
shooting at plain people because those
people needed
blood those people needed the war of
everybody against everybody
and this was done by our foreign
colleagues by the way and the same
started in ukraine and there is every
time the same scenario in all different
countries in serbia in russia and
ukraine in lithuania in
georgia in syria in libya and this
scenario is pretty much the same to
push
everybody against everybody to come to
the civil war and to introduce the blood
in all the
atrocities and they are then later on
bringing the democracy and by the way
there is no democracy no democracy in
america no democracy in russia no
democracy in france
it's just
very convenient
and this is what happened
here
and by the way if we will look at the
time before 2014.
before this year we were brothers and
sisters although ukraine was a separate
state but
starting from 2014
when in ukraine the maidan started
everything was changed and my friends
uh my close friends uh did not come here
to russia
vladimir putin who was supported by all
people everybody supported him yeah of
course there are some people some
influencers
in uh
theaters for example
actors who get some state money they
made some
pathological uh
pieces of art so to say but they are
making this for state money
even if they are not supporting the
russian government but the russian
government was providing there with
money for their theaters for their
movies for movie making in the radio for
example here in moscow in center could
you imagine this
the second world war the great patriotic
war
was
new york
and what would be if the
radio station
like from nazi germany would work in
new york in 1941 42 in paris or in
london but this was in moscow until now
now it is not the case
now the world will be changing and this
is right so the western world is also
stating there is
nothing
left from the past we are facing the new
civilization but what will be this new
civilization what does russia make right
now
by the way we are fighting not only for
luhansk for donetsk where russian people
are living who were waiting for eight
years they were killed by nazis for
eight years and the blood was shed
during eight years and we were waiting
and waiting
for what
we are now
fighting not only for luhansk city for
donetsk
we are
fighting not only for russia that ceased
to be exist in one year if we would
just look at this what was planned by
the collective west
si chassis
he could foresee this uh what you could
read you could read what he was speaking
about russian russia he was stating
his hope about russia and he was saying
that
michel nostradamus for example
uh he was speaking also about russia
what is the goal
is
of all of this is to save russia to save
ukraine
to exterminate nazism
and therefore the russian army is very
carefully coming through ukraine we are
only
cleaning this country out of nazism and
by the way we are
struggling to support to help the planet
and i think the goal of putting of
russia is only one to show to the planet
which is in the state of extinction
which is in the state of abandoning all
the christian values
like all the rules that were provided by
our ancestors do not kill do not steal
do love your father and mother
and the others
uh same sex uh connections uh same-sex
marriages and by the way what are you
doing here
what is this all for you wanted as the
collective west
to
us to live like this but we can
remember and we really support our
traditions and we are bringing in these
traditions we are showing that we
and you know russia is huge russia is
self-sufficient and by the way i lived
for the last 75 years
and i
have seen many things and there was
unknown for me why are we bearing this
because we see that this western world
in its agony it is dying
it is lying
and it is uh stating one thing signing
uh the contracts
international contracts that are legally
binding and then it is breaching this
contract and
our goal our aim is to show to the world
the model of the new civilization
harmonic civilization beautiful
civilization
which leaves
guided by the
traditions
okay thank you
i have a bunch of questions about what
you just said
so let me start
okay so
the belief you hear in the west is that
ukraine and belarus have been completely
separate forever and that it was just
during the soviet union that they were
combined with russia
is that true or is that propaganda
i just obviously don't get the question
really but i will try to
make a statement here during the soviet
union we were living in harmony russians
ukrainians bel russians we were one folk
one nation we could easily come to kiev
and they met us in the best way
they were greeting us our beloved
ukrainian brothers in belarus georgia
also in tajikistan in uzbekistan
you could come to every state within the
us and there was harmony and really open
friendly relations and then
there was the fallout of the ussr and i
was speaking also about this and later
on we've seen this uh small kingdoms
that started to breach the trust of the
russia we were supporting tajikistan uh
uzbekistan for example georgia we were
opening universities in these countries
in the former ussr we created the
national culture and this was done by
the russia by the soviet russia and by
the way in russia
even one folk not even one nation was
subject to genocide there were some
movement of a part of chechen people for
example when there were
seen in a misconduct but this was done
by stalin for example but not
any one
nation was
dying
and we were just supporting everybody
every nation
with the love and
as a sergey rabbinicki one of the famous
saints in russia in the 14th century he
was
stating and by the way i was making
about this particular time the movie
with uh andre tarkovsky and at that time
the russian saint
he was visited by the dmitry danskoi the
leader of russian nation
and he came to uh this saint and he told
him let us fight against the
tatar mongol
and he told please do not
use he do not do the atrocities we need
to combine all the powers and when the
time came the russian sentence
told to dmitry danskoi
go there and you will be victorious and
then dmitry danskoi
went
for the final battle and by the way now
for russia for putin we see this state
for escuelico
field for russia for ukraine for bill
russia for the whole world for you
what did you mean by there's no real
democracy
i wish status to anna yes
but do you think there is democracy
yes
so let us take a closer take a closer
look at it what is democracy
democracy is the power of people
that means uh do the people have the
power we don't know
we don't have
the
power that is coming from the people
that means we have to harmonize all
because
but what is happening around putin there
are so many oligarchs
who practically
were taking out the money and the
resources out of the russia out of the
people we are voting not for oligarchs
but for putin at the election the people
in russia
believe that putin will bring in order
there is no democracy at your side at
our side the democracy is uh just a show
off
it is just stating that the people have
a right to vote to choose between
something some someone but this is a
fraud every time
therefore i think that there is no
democracy in this sense
and there can not be
it cannot be the case i will add it here
it is impossible but
what can be possible do you think can be
possible that will be shown by russia in
russia
there is the notion in russian suburbs
that means this collectivity that means
gathering
we are gathered under a certain idea
high idea
we are gathered as the society and there
you have right to tell everything
that you are thinking about and make
right uh
steps and we will show it to the world
what is this
we can clean up our russia
because it's unfair that 500 oligarchs
have everything and hundreds of millions
of people
are at the verge of having no money at
all and we will push the order here and
we will show the new model to the world
okay
uh
can you explain what you mean by
the nazis you said the nazis were
fighting over the last eight years in
ukraine
so are you saying there are nazis in the
ukraine
yes
yes of course
because there are the marches of the
nazis in the center of kiev
uh
by the way they are pretty much at the
same time
they are showing the same times as the
hitler times like swastikas they're
using swastikas they're hailing each
other
there is the severe nationalism
i've seen this also 30 years ago
and we don't want to live under the
elderly brother under moscow okay you
may leave as they say but please why are
you
putting down the russian language there
is a great by the way russian
writer who was born in ukraine nikolai
gogol
and gogal was writing only in russian he
loved ukraine with all his heart because
you cannot love ukraine you have to love
ukraine when you see it once ukraine is
gorgeous but he was writing in russian
and then when somebody asked him why do
you not use ukrainian language he told
but how i can
use a dialect
when there is a language
of the great pushkin
he was the admirer of alexander pushkin
and he was writing in russian and by the
way
who is well renowned in ukraine the most
important
literary classics for
ukraine he was using russian language
and he loved russia
for example
so
ukraine said you couldn't use russia
russian language in ukraine
this is the case russian language is
banned in ukraine
it was banned and this is a part of
genocide of russian people this is
a killing of all russian and by the way
when you are killing all russian in
ukraine
you are killing yourself because earlier
ukraine was named kiev russia and this
was the heart of russian people and they
know about this
what international contracts are the
west breaking
actors
okay i will start by this
who was the ruler at that time
it was garbage of time
and he made a contract with the american
president
and with all european countries
about
the fact that
will be will stay there where it was
that natto will not come closer to
russia
by the way something was uh signed at
that time uh i think there was an
agreement of uh
of it but there was a breach and treason
and nada came to our borders closer and
closer step by step there were
uh taking uh to nato uh latvia georgia
the former soviet republics also poland
which was also a part of the soviet
influence
in yesteryears
uh this was a part of warsaw treaty
uh czech republic slovakia
they all were under control so to say by
the soviet union and nato took it though
nato was feeling it all and they came to
the borders of belarus
and they wanted and there were their
clans
as soon as possible to moscow and this
was prevented by putin
if we could wait for one year i think
one day
and if the operation was started not on
24th 25th
it would be already late because on 25th
there was the operation of ukrainian
and
the idea was to extinguish in three
hours donetsk and lugansk and come
further
and putin knew about these plans
because
we have our intelligence services and
putin was ahead of this plan
by 24 hours and ukrainian nazis in their
army were not
waiting for this
okay two questions um
so what happened in um donesk and
lugonsk or what's been going on in the
last
eight years there
yeah well
i was
in these republics
and i've seen really what is happening
there
because our friends are working there
in luhansk in the luhansk ukrainian
musical theater
i have my friends there and i visited
there
and they told me about
the
every day they were bombed
their relatives were dying they were
killed thousands of people
died
there was no russian army there were the
citizens of ukraine
and they were cut
from
the
support from kiev
they lost everything and keith did not
pay
their pension for example a retirement
pace and they tried to
kill them because they did not want to
be apart
of ukraine they did not want to
be under the ukrainian rule and i've
been in the villages i've seen these
children who are
in uh under their houses who are
living under the soil they lived in
under the buildings during the last
eight years
and nobody in the whole world was
speaking about this
at all
okay
what's wrong with nato
it's
because ask yourself against whom they
are
pushing all the weapons putting all the
weapons and stating all the weapons
earlier they were saying in naito that
they want to protect
the world against the terrorists
and
step by step they were coming to our
borders
against terrorists they said no it was
against us
they want russia they want the russian
territories because we are very rich we
are self-sufficient
no sanctions are bothering us yeah of
course it will be not so easy but russia
is uh aware of the uneasiness we
are
uh
still
i'm speaking uh not about you personally
when i'm speaking you or west
i can say that uh because of these
sanctions we will
turn out to be better we will support
our economy we will restore our culture
and support our culture and there will
be a reborn for russia i'm pretty sure
in it
okay
let me see we've covered a lot
in the western media it says that russia
has been attacking ukrainian civilians
is that true
absolutely
absolutely it's
absolutely like we are
supporting the civilians in ukraine we
are giving food to those people we are
entering into the territory uh the tons
of products
because
in the cities who are now
more relaxed like melee topol for
example we have seen the footages when
the soldiers are giving food to our
brothers because these are our brothers
and if we would do as america does in
syria in libya in iraq
when they're
tearing down
by the bombardments everything
everything would be already
at the verge of extinguishing
the people the architecture but we will
not do this at any cost because we are
russian
what role does the usa play in this war
if any
society
is usa is playing the major role in this
war
they were
burning the fire the initial fire
in our brother
in ukraine and our elderly brother by
the way
they were putting gasoline in this
burning fire
to make it
more and more out of it because the
americans will not fight by themselves
if everything
will happen with the participation of
americans if there will be a threat from
america we will use our records
we will use our weapons and therefore
biden is stating we will not interfere
we will not use the american army but of
course they are giving tons of weapons
of explosives to the ukrainian
expression to the brothers who
have to kill the brothers and by the way
the america
did it in the way that we are shedding
blood of each other the slavic blood the
russian blood in its sense
and this is
the worst case
and this
is for
this is the tragedy for russian for
ukrainians and the americans did it
but for this i think they will answer on
their soil and i think many leaders do
not believe in it what i am saying and
i've seen i've there i've been there i
know that there is the other world
behind the verge of the death and they
will face and they will have to answer
it
do you see this
ever getting to the point of using
nuclear weapons
about this there was a statement from
our president
about nuclear weapon
we have another military doctrine and
this is the other doctrine america
has the other doctrine than from russia
that it is stated in the military
doctrine of america that america could
also use pre-emptive strikes but we have
another military doctrine
we are um
as putin said
will come to hell and the others will
join the heaven
so definitely don't attack russia
i think biden understands this
the whole europe understands this nato
understands this and by the way
uh there is one moment that i wanted to
tell you about
when uh this
19 countries
were bombing yugoslavia i was there in
yugoslavia at that particular time
together with the people of belgrade
on the
bridges and i was speaking uh something
on behalf of russia to support our
brothers
and there
then when i was in belgrade
i've seen in on the television and by
the way it was seen by the whole world
as the
general staff uh head of the russian
army here in interview in moscow told
then well yes our
missiles can come in seven minutes to
london in five minutes to berlin
and there was a panic
i was
at
as a guest at my belgrade friends and
they called from berlin to them and
they told that the press in berlin was
afraid five minutes what about us why we
why do we
what are we having to do with all this
but we will not start the war
and we will
push the end to this war
and we will eliminate all the nazis also
in your name
okay so just to reiterate uh
russia went into
the ukraine
to fight nazis and that war has been
going on
for eight years or for longer than eight
years
for russia
these are seven days
this is the operation of
cleaning out of the territory of our
beloved ukraine
from the nazis and only seven days but
the nazis were killing their brothers in
donetsk in luhansk for last eight years
and russia did not interfere with the
military power russia was not
in war with ukraine
during this eight years although the all
western world is stating that russia is
fighting against ukraine during this
eight years but this is lies only lies
and for lies you will have to
answer uh all the journalists from the
all the world i know i understand you
are getting the money you need to
work on to get your money and you will
lie further you will as a journalist
speak lies about russia but russia is
not a fine number one russia is the
friend number one if russia says yes it
will be yes if russia says no it will be
no and we told no
how long do you think this
current war is going to last
we all are asking this question
and
you know our experienced uh
professionals from military
and we have
group alpha and these are
the super professionals
where one person has a value of 100
persons 100 specialists
i think groups alpha would make this in
three days
they could clean up all in three to five
days but russia is using the humane way
therefore it will take longer perhaps
one more week
and then
there will be another process process of
restoration
of ukrainian people of unity of
ukrainian peoples
and
it will make the pavement for them to go
back to their roots
it's not the west it's not nato ukraine
is uh of no value for nato
uh americans regular america americans
do not know where is ukraine they do not
need it they need only blood
there in ukraine for us to kill each
other and we will try to make as less
blood as possible
we'll try to do this and then there will
be a very long
process process of healing
process of redemption
of understanding why
we here why did we believe to these
nazis to this quasi historians that
said that the first guy
who was of ukrainian descent was a adam
created by the god and this is that this
is the separate folk separate nation
separate from russia
and this is uneasy it will take a long
time we have seen we have evidenced this
how the russophobes arusophobia people
were created in ukraine and
and this is the hate
what are your views on zelensky
if you ask me what i am thinking about
i can say that i am thinking he wants to
be my colleague he is uh
not an actor
i can speak about this as a professional
actor who is dealing with the 62 years
from the childhood of ivan the movie by
andrei tarkowski
he is a comedian
let me speak about the artist
uh my profession has put me in this
position that if somebody tells me that
i am an artist i would not agree with
this really because artist is somebody
who is playing a role and that means
that they are subject to the will of
some other people
and he is just a comedian and he is a
foul comedian and being a foul comedian
he wanted to play a role of the
president
but because of uh lack of understanding
he did not understand what he was doing
and
he was under guidance either and
everybody knows this america was guiding
these foul comics
he
was listening to them they told him
let's do the war
and
we don't want the war we want peace
and therefore
his
destiny is not a good one
he will be put on the altar and he will
be the one
who
will be used and
then fall apart
and or perhaps he will come somewhere
where
he has his money billions of dollars for
this selling
of russia and for this
possibility to be a
submissive
person under the feet of the usa
and then he is saying why
europe is not helping us we are a huge
country we are bigger than europe but
when we will be under the russia
we you will lose us give us the money so
he was landing and landing he was taking
all the money but he will pay the bills
and the bills are here
what happens after
russia
gets rid of
the nazis in the ukraine
are they going to stay there or are they
going to the russians going back to
russia
russians issues they are
organized
they are already on the ukrainian lands
but they used to live there through
these years
under oppression
uh having fears and now they can
really
have a deep breath in and you
they will not show you the chronicle uh
footages of the people who are happy
that there are no more aggressive
nationalists
in their neighborhood they will live
an easy life
but
unfortunately now we see that there are
young children young adults who are
subject to the ideology
then we will have to do something and
imagine it like this
if you ask somebody
who is wise that there is so much evil
in the world knowledgeable person would
say that we will not have to fight
against this
you will need to put another line a line
of harmony of love
of respect and
of
support this will be the line that will
be
put by the russia and by the way help
the help will be rendered
russia will have to render the help to
restore everything that was torn apart
that was deconstructed
during the last 30 years by those who
were governing ukraine and this process
will take a long time but what shall be
done russia got used to do it to help to
restore by the way you could see how the
crimea uh and sevastopol are restored
what are the investments that are coming
there uh there are new uh roads there
are new bridges how the people are
living this i could invite you to
sevastopol you could
see the people who are
having everyday
feast they are dancing they're they are
living well there
and i am an often guest guests
here is what is russia the russia brings
in peace and harmony
okay
i don't think i have any more questions
is there anything else you want to say
before we stop the podcast
what to say
we've
been talking
in a very open mode i think somebody
will not believe in the word that i am
stating because they are listening to
the other sources but even here in
russia i am every time uh speaking the
truth and by the way this
is a problem for the authorities for
example in russia because i say to some
of them that you
should not be
a
governing person here you don't
understand what you are doing but
perhaps when you listen to me you will
just think about what i was stating and
you will want to get to know the truth
and as the great russian poet
there is the sense of truth within the
human's heart and this sense of truth
deep in your heart
it will show itself in the people who
are listening to us right now
okay i have one more question and then
we'll end um
would you say that the average russian
citizen agrees with what you're saying
you know um
i think that's
98
of russians would agree with what i am
stating there is the so-called five
fifth column uh the last two percent
there will be and they were
these are the people who are not
admiring their nation who are thinking
that somewhere else is better
i think there is no country that is
better than russia we have everything we
have seas lakes we have baikal sea we
have deserts even we have everything we
have oil we have gas natural gas
we are self-sufficient
that we see the iron curtain right now
it is done by them not by us
i personally i would greet this i'm
happy because of this russia will be
stronger russia will show to the world
new civilization model
of salvation of human race
and i want to thank you
you are gorgeous and i
am glad to see you
thank you well thank you very much
nikolai for taking out the time and
coming on the podcast that was very
interesting
thank
you
and god help us definitely god help us
please do not forget about the gods
[Music]
you